und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka und abend die
kulisse malerisch die gesprächsthemen
hingegen brutal krieg hunger klimakrise
zu beobachten wie sich die staatenlenker
zu familienfotos vom bayerischen
bergpanorama aufstellten drückte fast
etwas so real wie eine parallelwelt in
die sich der ukrainische präsident heute
per video zugeschaltete immerhin die g7
familie hält wieder halbwegs zusammen
seitdem der mächtigste mann in ihrer
mitte nicht mit donald trump heißt
zugleich sieht sich die familie der
demokraten massiv von außen bedroht
russland und china machen aus ihrem
expansionsdrang keinen hehl mehr
russland greift dafür ja sogar zu den
waffen die g7 müssen darauf antworten
finden und verbündete aus garmisch
partenkirchen berichtet andreas kinder
alle beteiligten die fahrrad demo von
mittenwald nach gleis startet pünktlich
an diesem mittag für solidarität mit der
ukraine aber gegen die dämonisierung
putins beteiligte 3 die zwei anmelder
und ein polizist es ist nicht leicht
heute das g7-treffen zu kritisieren weil
die g7 heute ihre kritiker treffen fünf
staatenlenker denen die westliche runde
zu streng mit russland ist argentiniens
präsident ist für solidarität mit der
ukraine aber gegen die dämonisierung
putins südafrikas präsident vermeidet
den krieg krieg zu nennen senegals
präsident sieht sanktionen gegen
russland genauso kritisch die
indonesiens präsident und indiens
ministerpräsident hat den handel mit
russland seit beginn des kriegs sogar
verstärkt allein die erdölimporte
verdreifacht auf den krieg in der
ukraine blicken wir aus
unterschiedlichen perspektiven das
wissen alle gerade deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir miteinander darüber
sprechen unsere jeweiligen sichtweisen
auch austauschen
es soll offen gesprochen werden ohne
zurückhaltung ohne sakkos ihr müsst zur
kenntnis nehmen wird der inder modi
sagen dass wir am meisten leiden unter
teuren sanktionen frankreich und
deutschland werden erwidern ihr
kritisiert sanktionen etwa im
ernährungsbereich die es gar nicht gibt
so streiten auf einem schloss in bayern
der westen und der globale süden über
den krieg
die konfliktthemen zwischen der ukraine
und russland sind seit mehr als zehn
jahren gegenstand der globalen debatte
afrika wurde nie an einen tisch geladen
um diese themen zu diskutieren
deshalb kann man jetzt nicht sagen
entscheidet euch für die eine seite oder
die andere
auf die hohen gipfel hinter dem gipfel
zeigt olaf scholz bevor ihm einfällt
aber nicht so hoch wie im himalaya dass
es gelingt auch das geografische und
bevölkerungsreiche schwergewicht indien
zur unterschrift unter das gemeinsame
bekenntnis zum völkerrecht zu bewegen
schreibt sich deutschland als erfolg zu
aus der ukraine betrachtet präsident
selensky den gipfel in germany und kann
nur sagen was er immer sagt bitte helft
uns wenn der krieg nicht bis zum winter
beendet sei werde es schwierig sei
lenski ist zugeschaltet als die g7
beschließen ihren druck auf russland
weiter zu erhöhen
was im irak wirklich beeindruckt ist die
erstaunliche ausdauer und die
entschlossenheit die anhaltende
einigkeit der g7
die fahrer demo von mittenwald nach
gleis mit ihren zwei teilnehmern hat
übrigens friedlich ihr ziel erreicht sie
haben zwar unterwegs noch andere
demonstranten gesehen aber der g7 gipfel
und seine gäste waren nie in gefahr
in der tat es ist jedenfalls keineswegs
so als würde putins angriffskrieg in
allen weltregionen genau so verdammt wie
in europa oder den usa das wird die
große frage der nächsten jahre wie viele
weitere staaten die großen 7 an sich
binden können auch ob sie sich erweitern
sollten etwa um pazifische demokratien
die australien und neuseeland und wie
sich asiatische arabische und
afrikanische staaten positionieren dass
das demokratie modell gegenüber den
chinesischen oder russischen überall
attraktiver ist davon darf man ja leider
nicht ausgehen und auch wirtschaftlich
haben die g7 längst nicht mehr die
dominanz vergangener jahrzehnte
eine analyse von thomas reichert der
chef um arme auf diesem g7 gipfel ist
eindeutig emanuel macom frankreichs
präsident lässt indiens premier modi gar
nicht mehr los als wollte er ihn
festhalten oder persönlich ins lager der
g7 ziehen und genau darum geht es die g7
brauchen verbündete in der ringen mit
putin zunächst mal darf man nicht in die
falle tappen die putin aufstellt zu
behaupten die welt sei geteilt und dem
globalen westen also die g7 und ihre
freunde im norden und alle anderen das
stimmt ja nicht demokratien gibt es in
der ganzen welt und sie haben sehr
ähnliche perspektiven kurz vor allem
aber gab es einen anderen eine art
gegengipfel die ting ting chinas staats-
und parteichef hat eine botschaft an die
anderen bric staaten russland südafrika
brasilien und indien müssten gegen den
westen und den missbrauch
internationaler sanktionen
zusammenstehen und wladimir putin durfte
behaupten an der drohenden hungerkrise
sei dass selbst richtige handeln des
westens shipping versucht russlands
krieg zu nutzen für seine ganz eigenen
ziele kurzfristig geht es erstmal darum
auch putin sozusagen den rücken zu
stärken ihnen salonfähig zu machen
mittelfristig ist das ein versuch gegen
macht bildung zu betreiben die eigenen
plattformen netzwerke auch zur
durchsetzung der eigenen interessen dann
nutzbar zu machen dass nicht die ganze
welt den besten dabei folgt russland
angriffskrieg zu verurteilen das zeigte
schon die un vollversammlung
märz viele enthielten sich auch die
aktuellen g7 gastländer indien und
südafrika argentinien indonesien und
weniger stimmten für die resolution aber
auch sie stehen zwischen den lagern sich
als präsident etwa besuchte putin anfang
juni in sochi und zeigte verständnis für
russlands position
und in südafrika musste sich olaf scholz
kurz zuvor harsche kritik des
staatspräsidenten an den westlichen
sanktionen gegen russland anhören
die gegen russland verhängten sanktionen
werden sich auch auf jene länder
auswirken die entweder am rande des
konflikts stehen oder gar nicht daran
beteiligt sind
putin und die wollen den fonds gegenüber
dem westen nutzen sie bauen an einem
anti westlichen glauben sie doch die
seit jahren mit dem projekte neuen
seitenstraße des anderen ländern
milliardenschwere kredite verspricht für
infrastruktur aber dort ostende den
milliardenschwere verschuldung
die g7 wollen dagegenhalten versprechen
hilfen über 600 milliarden dollar in den
nächsten fünf jahren
wir bieten ländern und deren bürgern auf
der ganzen welt bessere möglichkeiten in
kritische infrastruktur zu investieren
hier leben und unser aller leben
verbessern und echte vorteile bringen
und zwar für uns alle nicht nur für die
g 7
die frage ist wie überzeugend das
angebot ist wie weit sich die
unentschiedenen länder herüber ziehen
lassen ins lager des westens
anne gellinek beobachtet diesen gipfel
für uns im moment aus dem pressezentrum
weil es draußen die haus kübeln schüttet
an dem was was war dein eindruck ist es
gelungen länder wie indien oder sie
legal die westliche perspektive ja ich
sag mal verständlicher zu machen
also verständlicher deutlicher zu machen
vielleicht ja aber der blickwinkel der
eingeladenen länder auf den ukrainer
kriegt ist doch ein völlig anderer
länder aus in afrika oder auch indien
oder indonesien sehen den ukraine krieg
als einen europäischen regional konflikt
der erst mal mit ihnen überhaupt nichts
zu tun hat dessen auswirkungen sie aber
extrem stören weil eben die getreide die
lebensmittel- und energiepreise steigen
und so sah sich der westen heute hier
mit gästen konfrontiert die gesagt haben
löst doch bitte diesen konflikt und
lasst uns lasst uns bitte mit euren
sanktionen in ruhe werden es gehört der
senegalesische präsident macht sich ja
sogar putins argumente zu eigen und sagt
die westlichen sanktionen seien für die
getreide krise verantwortlich also hier
sind heute zwei sehr unterschiedliche
sichtweisen aufeinander geprallt man hat
einander bearbeitet aber so richtig
näher gekommen ist man sich wohl nicht
diese konflikte die könnten dann ja mit
voller wucht aufbrechen wenn im november
der g20-gipfel ansteht wenn alle
aufeinander treffen also einschließlich
russland und china
ja das war hier sehr interessanten
offenbar haben europäer und amerikaner
hier auf dem gipfel in ellmau sich
überlegt wie verhalten wir uns auf
diesen g20 gipfel und die entscheidung
getroffen wir wollen diesen gipfel der
im november in bali stattfindet auf
keinen fall den autokratien überlassen
die europäer und amerikaner wollen eben
nicht dass es eine neue anti westliche
allianz aus indien china und russland
gibt sondern sie haben gesagt wir fahren
bewusst hin olaf scholz hat das heute
morgen auch genauso angedeutet wir
fahren hin und sagen putin die meinung
der indonesische präsident machte heute
einen ziemlich unglücklichen eindruck
hier weil er wohl ahnt dass das nächste
treffen das g20-treffen ein ziemlich
konfrontative werden wird allerdings
dankeschön an die einschätzung nach
hätten heute schon ein update gibt es
noch ein interessantes gesprächen der
südafrikanischen außenministerin das
wulf schmiese geführt hat und während in
schloss elmau noch getagt wird richten
sich die blicke von dort schon auf das
nächste großereignis den nato gipfel in
madrid der morgen beginnt
nato-generalsekretär ist oldenburg hat
angekündigt dass das bündnis seine
sogenannten schnellen eingreifkräfte von
rund 40.000 auf mehr als 300.000 erhöht
als antwort auf die russische bedrohung
das ist ein vorsichtig gesagt schon
ziemlich drastischer schritt über den
wir gleich auch noch mehr reden vorab
erklärt franziska von tiesenhausen kurz
was ist mit diesem speziellen nato
truppen auf sich hat
im nato-hauptquartier erhöht man den
druck auf russland ein massiver ausbau
der kapazitäten ist geplant einen tag
vor dem nato-gipfel skizziert
generalsekretär stoltenberg erste
schritte new concept unser neues konzept
wird uns in einer ära des strategischen
wettbewerbs leiten ich erwarte dass
durch das klarmacht dass das bündnis
russland als größte und direkteste
bedrohung unserer sicherheit sieht
das bündnis will unter anderem die so
genannte schnelle eingreiftruppe umbau
über die nato seit 20 jahren verfügt um
im krisenfall rasch reagieren zu können
sie umfasst zurzeit rund 40.000
soldatinnen und soldaten nach russlands
einmarsch in die ukraine wurde ein teil
der schnellen eingreiftruppe erstmals
verlegt unter anderem nach rumänien
künftig will die nato fast achtmal so
viele soldatinnen und soldaten für
kurzfristige einsätze bereit halten
derweilen der ukraine weiter brutal
gekämpft wird und putin raketen hageln
lässt an vielen orten zugleich raketen
die großflächig zerstören und zivile
ziele treffen in der großstadt
krementschouk in der zentral ukraine
bombardierten die russen an
einkaufszentrum in dem sich nach
ukrainischen angaben zu dem zeitpunkt
mehr als 1000 menschen aufhielten bei
dem angriff starben mindestens 13
menschen
krementschouk ist über 100 kilometer von
der front im osten entfernt dort sind
inzwischen die deutschen panzerhaubitzen
eingetroffen unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf bekam sie zu sehen wir müssen
uns durch die büsche an der frontlinie
im osten schlagen mitten in einem
waldstück steht eine der deutschen
panzerhaubitzen gut versteckt es ist das
erste mal dass die ukrainische armee
journalisten mit hier hinnimmt ruslan
ist gerade vor fünf tagen aus
deutschland zurück 36 tage lang wurde er
dort ausgebildet in technik und taktik
der zeitdruck für sie ist enorm denn die
russische armee rückt im osten immer
weiter vor kommt die lieferung der
haubitzen zu spät werden möchte ich
glaube es ist zu spät fiel zu spät warum
wir hätten schon vor dem 24 februar
vorbereitet sein sollen es war bekannt
dass die russen uns angreifen würden sie
werden uns nur lassen wir hätten
rechtzeitig darauf vorbereitet sein
sollen
seit wochen kämpfen sie auf verlorenem
posten
einer der soldaten für dürfen sein
gesicht nicht zeigen führt uns ein video
von ihren einsätzen mit völlig
veralteter technik vor doch jetzt soll
sich alles ändern 12 haubitzen sieben
aus deutschland und fünf aus den
niederlanden sind jetzt in der ukraine
angekommen wo sie eingesetzt werden auch
das streng geheim
egal in welcher armee der welt die
artillerie ist das erste ziel für den
gegner besser ausschalten will denn
diese technik ist für den feind
besonders gefährlich
es gibt nicht viel was wir an diesem
morgen an der frontlinie zeigen dürfen
auch das innere der panzerhaubitze soll
ein geheimnis bleiben darum erzählen sie
hätten die deutschen ausbilder sie
gebeten
ihre seite hat uns gebeten nicht im
inneren zu filmen sie hatten angst dass
informationen über die technik in die
hände der besatzer fallen
welcome to use change haben sie auf die
front geschrieben ein provokanter
willkommensgruß an die russen auch das
ist teil der kriegsführung
so geschaltet ist gustav gräßel
militärexperte hat bei der
österreichischen armee eine
offiziersausbildung auch selbst
durchlaufen und das forscher am european
council on foreign relations mit
schwerpunkten der strategie hallo guten
abend herr kressl guten abend diese
panzerhaubitzen können die einen
unterschied machen
für die einheiten in denen sie kämpfen
natürlich ist eine sehr gute panzer pc
mobiles feuer geschützt hat mir sehr
große reichweite natürlichen jetzt zwölf
stück an einer frontlinie die
1200 kilometer lang sind jetzt nichts
das den krieg als ganzes wendet aber
muss sagen diese diese panzerhaubitzen
sind teil eines weiteren hilfspaketes
der alliierten also nicht nur
deutschlands dass die ukraine in die
lage versetzt die nato munition also 150
mm zu verschießen weil die eigene
artillerie munition ausgeht und die
produktion für russische artillerie
kaliber im westen knapp es um solche
sicher hinein ein gutes und
wirkungsvolles mittel der unterstützung
die kämpfe konzentrieren sich jetzt zum
teil auf relativ kleine bereiche wenn
man sich jetzt das riesenland ukraine
ankommt person raketen fliegen überall
aber diese stellungskrieg mit panzern
das sind ja eingegrenzte bereiche kann
da wenn man diese haubitzen konzentriert
kann daran wirklich so was wie eine
rückeroberung von piero donetsk oder
ähnliches möglich sein da überschätzt
man dann diese art von waffe das ist ja
moderne schwere artillerie
sie wird in erster linie dazu eingesetzt
gegnerische artillerie anzugreifen
dadurch dass sie eine sehr hohe
reichweite hat kann man die hinter der
front stehende russische artillerie die
die ukraine beschießt angreifen da sie
eine sehr genaue warf er ist kann das
auch sehr punktgenauer folgen und dafür
ist ece ist ja auch gut und ausgelegt
große gegenangriffe zum beispiel die
rückeroberung von einer ganzen stadt
dazu brauchst natürlich mehr als nur
artillerie da brauchen dann auch
kampfpanzer da braucht man auch
schützenpanzer und da braucht man auch
ein endlager ganzen front ein
kräfteverhältnis dass man dass man das
durchhalten kann das ist für die ukraine
zur zeit schwierig also in einigen front
bereichen haben sie eine überlegenheit
und versuchen die russen zurückzudrängen
aber dort wo russland selber das
schwergewicht setzt da ist die
überlegenheit der russen zahlenmäßig
einfach noch zu groß das haben jetzt
eben auch gerade in diesem leben schon
erwähnten und inzwischen auch er wäre
oder netz bekannten ort in deutschland
bekannten ort beobachtet dass die
ukrainische seite dann sagt er wir
ziehen uns jetzt zurück und die nannten
das einen taktischen rückzug können sie
uns nicht militärs erklären was ein
taktischer rückzug ist ja das problem
ist die ukrainische seite versucht um
die städte so lange wie möglich zu
kämpfen weil sie in den städten sich mit
der infanterie gut bewegen kann mit
ihren leichten panzer waffen relativ
viel russisches gerät zerstören kann in
der offenen feldschlacht hat sich das
problem dass sie aufgrund der mangel an
kampfpanzer und schützenpanzern sich
nicht so leicht bewegen und nicht so
leicht das gefecht führen kann jetzt ist
das problem die servierten jetzt geht er
nicht gefallen weil die ortschaft selber
und verteidigt wurde oder weil russland
dort die kräfte zusammen geführt hat um
die ortschaft selber zu stürmen sondern
weil sich im süden der stadt ein anderes
gefecht für die russen entschieden hat
und dann bestand die lage dass diese
stadt entweder eingekesselt wird oder
die ukraine ziehen sich zurück und da
haben sie sich natürlich zurückgezogen
damit sie nicht eingekesselt werden wie
schätzen sie dann ins gesamte moment die
lage an sie sagten da fehlen panzer zum
beispiel waren zahllose haubitzen
reichen eben dann doch nicht
wie gesagt das ist ein abnutzungskrieg
und es ist der krieg derzeit mit der
zwei grössten land armeen in europa das
heißt zwölf sitzen so gut sie auch sind
sie natürlich nicht das ende der
fahnenstange
kampfpanzern die lieferungen aus polen
aus der show republik gerade mal die
kriegsverluste ausgeglichen die die
ukraine bis jetzt erlitten hat aber um
jetzt wirklich auch wieder zum
gegenschlag sondern größeren gegenschlag
auszuholen reicht das bis jetzt nicht
auch bei den schützenpanzern klafft eine
sehr große lücke bei den ukrainern und
die zu füllen wird schwierig sein die
die amerikaner könnten hier noch größere
waffenlieferungen im herbst bringen
sonst ist der leider recht wenig
angekündigt und das ist das problem der
ukraine sie verfügen zwar über viele
leute sie haben eine mobilmachung
angeordnet sie haben einen sehr hohen
zuspruch an freiwilligen aber diese
kampfbereiten leute männer und frauen
bestehen jetzt als leichte infanterie
das heißt leute mit gewehren leute mit
gürtel gestützten waffen und im offenen
gelände außerhalb von ortschaften
außerhalb von großen wäldern können die
natürlich in der beweglichkeit und in
der feuerkraft in der reichweite ihrer
feuerkraft mit einem anzahl oder
russischen gepanzerten verbänden nicht
mithalten die natur denkt außerdem auch
noch über ihr eigenes territorium nach
mit der erhöhung der anzahl von soldaten
soldatinnen für die schnelle
eingreiftruppe
das ist ja erstmal eine enorme zahl von
40.000 auf 300.000 man fragt sich fast
ein bisschen wo kommen die plötzlich
alle her das ist in der tat die frage so
da werden wir in der bewertung noch mal
abwarten müssen wie man sich das auch
vorstellen das hieß ja die schnelle
eingreiftruppe müsse binnen 30 tagen
einsatzbereit sein und das wäre
natürlich für 300.000 man schon eine
steilvorlage das natürlich die response
force größer werden muss das ergibt sich
von selbst die die russischen
streitkräfte den ukrainer einmarschiert
sind in der minderzahl viermal so groß
wie die ganze nato response force das
problem ist aber auch so schnell so
viele leute einsatzbereit zu machen das
wird sich finanziell und das wird sich
auch von unserer man stärke wir sind ja
auch alten der gesellschaften wir haben
nicht wie im kalten krieg ein ewiges
pool an jungen leuten die alle zur armee
gehen das für sie schwierig darstellen
also da bin ich mal gespannt welche
zeitleisten welchen welche
zusammensetzung man da eigentlich an
denkt und wie man das machen will sagt
experte gustav russell dunking vielen
dank zum kriegsgeschehen und seinen
vielfältigen
globalen folgen finden sie natürlich wie
immer auch jede menge informationen
videos und hintergründe online auf zdf
heute und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf
weiter mit anderen nachrichten des tages
die für energie zuständigen
ministerinnen und minister der eu länder
haben in luxemburg über die
versorgungssituation beraten
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe betonte
die bedeutung der solidarität
untereinander die versorgungssicherheit
sie tabak derzeit gewährleistet mit
blick auf den winter müssten die
speicher gefüllt der verbrauch gesenkt
und mehr kapazitäten organisiert werden
über den winter droht ein szenario das
tatsächlich reduktion gesetzlich
verordnet werden müssen das würde dann
meine antike nach zu einer schweren
wirtschaftskrise in europa und in
deutschland führen das gilt es unbedingt
zu vermeiden
gut sieben wochen nach der landtagswahl
in schleswig holstein haben cdu und
grüne auf zwei landesparteitagen über
den ausgehandelten koalitionsvertrag
beraten und ihm jeweils mit großer
mehrheit zugestimmt die wiederwahl von
cdu-ministerpräsident daniel günther ist
für mittwoch geplant
zum auftrag der zweiten ozean konferenz
der vereinten nationen haben politiker
wissenschaftler und vertreter von
nichtregierungsorganisationen
mit emotionalen appellen zum schutz der
weltmeere aufgerufen un generalsekretär
ban sprach in seiner eröffnungsrede vom
notstand der meere zu den bedrohungen
für die weltmeere gehören laut un unter
anderem die globale erwärmung und
verschmutzung ziel der konferenz ist
eine gemeinsame erklärung um den schutz
der ozeane zu fördern
im vergangenen jahr sind so viele
menschen aus der katholischen kirche
ausgetreten wie noch nie es waren knapp
360.000 der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz bätzing nannte die
zahlen erschütternd und sagte diese
kirche müsse sich verändern sonst
verliere sie immer mehr menschen
der ukrainische schriftsteller und
musiker sehr hübscher dann wird mit dem
diesjährigen friedenspreis des deutschen
buchhandels ausgezeichnet
der 47 jährige gilt als eine der
wichtigsten stimmen der ukrainischen
gegen lau dass literatur geehrt werde
schaden der in der umkämpften stadt
aktiv lebt sowohl für sein
herausragendes literarisches werk als
auch für seine humanitäre haltung unter
einsatz seines lebens so der
stiftungsrat der friedenspreis wird am
23 oktober in der frankfurter
paulskirche verliehen
jetzt der blick auf den finanzmarkt und
damit heute zur frage wie es um die
internationale
zahlungsfähigkeit russland steht frank
bethmann es geht konkret um
zinszahlungen auf auslandsschulden genau
von denen russland behauptet man habe
diese zinszahlungen längst geleistet bei
den gläubigern in taiwan ist dieses geld
aber nicht angekommen konnte auch nicht
ankommen die westlichen finanzsanktionen
verhindern dies macht es für den kreml
mittlerweile unmöglich gläubiger im
ausland mit entsprechenden devisen zu
bedienen bestätigt auch jörg krämer der
chefvolkswirt der commerzbank der
zahlungsausfall liegt also nicht daran
dass russland nicht zahlen will sondern
aufgrund der sanktionen dazu nicht in
der lage ist experten sprechen von einem
technischen zahlungsausfall keinesfalls
vergleichbar mit dem russischen
staatsbank ort im jahr 1998 unter dem
vor über 100 jahren vor der russischen
revolution dass russland von heute ist
nicht zahlungsunfähig im klassischen
sinne moskaus devisenreserven werden mit
knapp 600 milliarden dollar angegeben
und die hälfte davon aber sind blockiert
das land ist gering verschuldet die
schuldenquote liegt bei nur 20 prozent
und es verdient weiterhin milliarden
dollar aus energieexporten dass russland
seine auslandsschulden und trotzdem
nicht bedienen kann zeigt dass die
wirtschaftsblockade erste wirkungen
zeigen
entscheidend schwächen tun sie das land
aber noch nicht mit einer drastischen
rubel entwertung oder gar einem kollaps
des bankensystems wird vorerst nicht
gerechnet die börsen jedenfalls
reagierten heute kaum auf diesen
technischen bankrott frank bethmann
vielen dank
es gibt aktuelle unwetterwarnungen des
deutschen wetterdienstes gewarnt wird
vor schweren gewittern mit heftigem
starkregen und hagel in teilen von
bayern sachsen und sachsen anhalt
zum sport nach gold silber und bronze
hat florian wellbrock bei der schwimm wm
in budapest auch in seinem vierten final
rennen edelmetall gewonnen gold über die
fünf kilometer im lukas
11 ist unser freund mit silber an den
italiener petrini und bronze an
schwimmen kumpmann schock aus der
ukraine
florian wellbrock hat sich
freigeschwommen im freiwasser mit einer
machtdemonstration aus gold und bastelt
sich in budapest ein kleeblatt aus wm
medaillen aus silber und bronze im
becken wird nach dem sieg in der
mixed-staffel das erste einzel gold über
fünf kilometer gefeiert und gedrückt von
genau den leuten die er sich auf dem
podium gewünscht hat am mittwoch über
zehn kilometer ist favorit wellbrock
olympiasieger und titelverteidiger aus
solchem holz sind sportler des jahres
geschnitzt
das war von uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht es mit dem montagskino weiter um 23
55 gibt es dann unser heute schon als
update mit nazan guckte mir und dann hat
er schnell wieder sind für sind
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es ist ja einiges los im moment
etliche schauer und gewitter nach norden
hin aber die musik spielt vor allem im
süden hier sind heftige gewitter
unterwegs teils mit starkregen und hagel
und auch sturmböen sie sehen es hier
diese violetten flächen teils mit
punkten also hier ist hagel dabei unter
ist seine aktuelles bild schauen uns das
mal genauer an und wenn sie mal genauer
hinschauen da klopfen quasi die schauer
und gewitter vor allem diese diese
zentren hier auf und bilden teilweise ja
auch strukturen und dann wird es
besonders heftig der wind legt zu und
der starkregen ist dann besonders
intensiv ja wie entwickelt sich das
weiter das ganze zieht allmählich nach
nordosten wird schwächer werden im laufe
der nacht und morgen gibt es neue
schauer und gewitter von süden her mit
einem tief von den alt nordalpen
herkommen hier schauer und gewitter auf
werden aber nicht ganz so heftig sein
wie die aktuellen schauen wir auf die
temperatur in der nacht 19 grad gibt es
nach osten hin acht bis neun grad
teilweise nur im vest die tiefsten
temperaturen
hier spürt man die kühlere luft die
eingeflossene ist und morgen ziehen die
letzten schauer im osten ab im süden
eben diese neuen gewitter die von süden
her auch aufziehen ansonsten sehr viel
sonnenschein mit höchsten temperaturen
mit 25 bis 28 grad in der mitte kühler
ganz im süden bei 21 oder an den küsten
um 22 grad weitere schauer und gewitter
erwarten uns am mittwoch zum beispiel
nach süden bei 28 grad und am donnerstag
geht es wieder knapp über die 30 grad
marke damit einen schönen abend